[Music]
not for me
news not for me submitted by empty
fortune cookie who you know what that
means in Chinese culture that's not for
me you're gonna die
damn really no I had one of those before
yep bad Feng shooey young puddle claims
prostitution is rife with in the fashion
industry
no but they're so skinny you don't say
I think it's rape in a lot of industries
yeah like acting and [ __ ] I bet you
ticket somewhere in their career how
about in comedy
wait you don't know for sure when you
know any dirty secrets and comedy can't
get anywhere without second dick that's
true
how'd you get how'd you get to college I
got this job by sucking dick yeah I will
say this though how about we put a
positive women can get somewhere if they
suck dick positivity pretty good it's a
work faster yes but see guys can't use
their body for that [ __ ] I wish we were
they can be so hairless there's I bet
there's a lot of guys that have done the
gay for pay to get gay for pay to get
somewhere I have gotten a promotion yeah
oh yeah that's how Brandon Rath was
Superman's too that's what I heard he
sucked a producer off no the Bryan
Singer the director I heard him and him
in Brandon yeah that's the word anyway
that's the word a lot of rumors about a
lot of famous people do that [ __ ] hey
that's how you know you're famous as
rumors about you
yeah sucking dick didn't get me anywhere
I still have to agree with so much work
and you're just sit there like Godzilla
you use suck dick and monogamy
see you're not doing random
yeah you're not climbing the corporate
ladder yeah you're doing the voted penis
sucking that's didn't kill me anyway
this woman uh her name is jazz she's 20
years old she's us austrian-born but is
based in London she's been modeling
since she was 13 she took part in
Germany's Next Topmodel
she named herself jazz or she was
important that way industry name yeah
probably so she has 35,000 Instagram
followers of you guys were curious so
she's claiming that big agencies and
established models are being are
involved in this seedy underground
dealings where young women are paid up
to two million dollars to spend the
night with male clients this is a
problem
so she's just so the reason why I'm
exposing 2 million was a lot higher than
I would expect that [ __ ] dude right a
my [ __ ] entire banks in the yearly
yearly salary I have never heard of two
million dollars for having that is just
mind-blowing it's like Heidi or
what's-her-name Heidi my lady glue no
not Heidi Klum the other one Karlie
Kloss the one for the closet oh my god
I'm blinking underneath just as a sister
did you hit up GG I said maybe huh
GG yeah I feel like what if it's hurt Oh
or like like a Victoria's Secret model
or like what is Elle budgin like wall
she's married to Tom Mann I think for me
like prostitution hasn't has a monetary
limit you know don't put the same tiled
prostitution with two million dollars
you know yeah this one's a call girl
like a yes one sounds so cheap I say
like two million dollars you're a
[ __ ] dope as business woman yeah yeah
at two million dollars you're just a hot
commodity at two million dollars most
guys are like yeah honey I think you
should do it yeah like it's like that
Robert Redford movie right oh yeah
Indecent Proposal or whatever yeah
for two million all these snacks what's
the audience amount let's at least I
mean you're talking to Joe with five
dollars five dollars
yeah r29 tell me how much you what what
answer I don't know what is the amount
that will make you happy
no what's the amount that you yeah if
someone said I'm gonna buy your
girlfriend for one night and you said
just know that there's no right answer
these ones gonna end up in are you
Monroe bollywood billionaire go even
better okay so are we poor
we're right now where we are right now
yeah we are right now I would have to
say
ten dollars no has to be more than okay
I can't even get a meal for that much so
I would have to say you get to keep ah
yes exactly
ten million ten million oh you're such a
[ __ ] liar ten million what's the real
number he's trying to play a safe right
now he's like [ __ ] playing it safe just
means that you're gonna get in trouble
ten million you better be the [ __ ] yeah
you better be the [ __ ] best damn elf
I'm worth 10 million because that's
gonna require some stuff that you don't
really you gotta get people to trust
that require like sucking ass [ __ ]
yourself out that's when you ask to eat
a really heavy me heavy meal first
yeah nice heavy life yeah I know and you
may and you have make sure the guy eats
like a lot of Italian food or something
you know I'm standard Mexican food like
I cuz then later on he's like I'm not
sure I'm hold on you know like that kind
of [ __ ] 10 million that means he cares
about you a lot
he's a liar what do you think his actual
number isn't I'm trying to get it out of
them what do you think it is though I
don't know Oh
Joe look at me honey okay yeah but you
so are you hundred we're sharing he goes
lower than that
are you keeping or sharing you didn't
put that in the equation yeah okay or if
we're sharing that do it for anything
what I would not do it for this family
babies this big family baby
I'll eat bones city I would do it if I
could but didn't nobody wants to pay me
within us yeah you know Stan yeah baby
you're beautiful porcelain doll baby
that's why people want to touch on you
you know
don't use glow but you wouldn't do it
for a million dollars 12 million 40
million dollars oh my god I'm gonna die
for by no BUTT STUFF but what else but
what other stuff you have to make love
to like you love them kind of [ __ ]
coat hangers and like [ __ ] you like
vanilla it has to be passionate as [ __ ]
you have to look at me the eyes and
every now and then he'll spit in your
mouth all that other stuff that you
worry I don't like anything else well
you have to eat the but no then no you
are eatable
you are eating the but for this family
that's right well I miss a meal if I
don't do this
no so I don't need it 10 million is a
lot you eat the one hole she's down hey
you got a good one job good
congratulations fifty grand
she is my 50 grand she is my girl but
you know what let's aren't we you've got
a value to yourself like in the right
market know what the thing is
I'm Titus and you die like wow
categories is curable now it's okay
thank you
if we're poor or not poor good answer oh
poor Norwich yeah but if we're at our
state of now that's not even a to cover
a year's worth of income so I would
think that's all thinking about I'm
thinking businessman first so I go ten
million so I could put that [ __ ] away
you are at the income that you were when
I met you 50 grand is fish Wow I'll be
ready with the mouthwash baby just
whenever you're done you would not be
able to make that baby it's because
we're better negotiators baby these two
girls they actually go through with it
right how would you guys feel after
getting I would never [ __ ] touch this
[ __ ] again
I'm never touching this organ I don't
know 50 grand is 50 grand is not a lot
it is a lot but you know what at the
match it's two milk bag drive away your
old boy who's the real loser I got ten
million bucks you're gone by the trunk
of my car my rules well yeah I took the
money we don't work it's all yours
he gets a hundred bucks hundred dollars
he didn't even do anything any of that
ago she ation nah he's the one that
broke her the deal you should get 15%
how did I cut in the lawyer - come on I
hate him and so she's saying that it was
an agent and an exclusive London Club
offered her an image modeling job and so
it involves a Greek yacht trip with
three millionaires she ended up
declining she said that she was a model
and not an escort so this is when he
started playing so first of all here but
like I kind of like multiple guys at one
time scenario like maybe I would do it
if it was that really did you get
sandwiched by three facts I think I'm
the same I would totally do it if it
because like this is never gonna happen
again
yeah but there guy is no but three guys
are yes yeah but it's three whales three
same guys dog
it's not like it's not like three guys
and their ones like okay looking and the
other ones like dicen I'm talking about
three guys named hunter agender Laguna
and he is like 500 pounds gold chain DJ
Khaled mikonos yeah this guy clearly
eats a lot of her mind
yeah and women always tell him you
should shave his body and he's like oh
no no thank you
[Laughter]
you know here she is again and then she
posted it or she released these
screenshots of her conversation with
this George I want to read this oh damn
you Joe yeah like barely bored his face
she's two million no she was offered a
different amount private meet with one
of my best clients in children firehouse
hotel young handsome Aiden Iranian guy
drinks top followed by natural intimacy
client is a famous actor name cannot be
disclosed girl required to wear heels
and nice dress behavior must be
demonstrated exquisite class fluent
English only pay two thousand pounds
that's it how much does that mean like
three thousand dollars oh Jesus
but the wait till I afford more what's
the next one to listen and then her
response was natural antipathy excuse me
but I'm a model not an escort and then
he sends a photo of the millionaire that
guy doesn't look hairy beggar girl looks
kind of hot well this agent says that he
only has his girls go to really
attractive handsome millionaires you see
that not naked knows that's not Mykonos
it's a trap it's not real
we don't know first trap he look like
that in the 90s please [ __ ] everyone
enjoys having think about the life they
come from they realize the value of
money and how much of a difference it
can make and every enjoys having sex
especially with young good-looking yeah
what is shame society creates double
standards that make women feel guilty
about what
you are you talked me out of it that's
good use it to your advantage surprising
but most models got to where they were
there was something like this you meet
amazing ly wealthy people that can
assist and propel your life and whatever
the Russian you want because now it's
condescending so before I was like oh
it's kind of cute mirror I'd do it no
it's condescending I'm like [ __ ] you to
be what do you want to end up I'm so
tired of this body standards were women
who are attractive think they cannot get
paid money facility god [ __ ] it up so
every guy that would make negative
comments about such things would get in
t do the same thing if a beautiful girl
proposed him what parties there isn't me
what the hundred guys no judgment but if
you can get something or all of those
bottling agencies are owned by hedge
fund managers want to because the head
booker blank flies around my client it's
jet LOL because i laugh good night humor
that is how the fashion industry works
same way photographers that grows into
sex in exchange for booking the job yeah
so that so he sent her all those
messages trying to convince her to do it
she was still like no and then he ends
up sending her two screenshots of
preview of previous conversations he had
with other girls that he convinced to do
this so for example this one message
I'll be the girl David will be the guy
she says something at Cambridge this is
my final year a smart girl did I am
which is why I was very skeptical of
this at first but I like money and
equally I like adventures this is own
account like talking to each other
I told you I am very open and honest
person everything I receive well I can
tell that now I guess it was fun with
that guy I liked it so I was so fake the
other one says the girl starts with Jack
being in writing a script by himself
yeah you there hello I'm out
left about 30 minutes ago it was so fun
yeah surprised if it's normally that
easy I'd be keen to do it again with
other people easy and fun loves to have
good sex and fun football and
disease-free like a [ __ ] yelp review
oh my god that's so good jazz expose
this and her goal is she says quote
there's so much wrong with this industry
and I'm going to do whatever it takes in
order to change it it might take
centuries but you have to start
somewhere so there's gonna be a couple
of girls I'm gonna [ __ ] your ass up
because you're [ __ ] nobody I don't
think she's exposed to you then who
doesn't think that there's escort girls
in any entertainment industry all these
Instagram that's what Institute that's
what Vegas is that's what a lot of music
people I've never taught the modeling
industry had high-class women give me a
[ __ ] app scoop even celebrities
negotiate deals to date each other they
like to have contracts there's a whole
book of people that are learning looking
to like date to boost their career oh
it's so like they have a fake
relationship to like yeah and it works
it like it boosts both of profiles I
love that because you're a model you're
therefore classy yeah that doesn't make
that doesn't jive with me it has to be
part of who you are not for things yeah
it's two separate things
yeah I guess she's doing the class yes I
put models next to like rock stars and
athletes and just people that like to
party people that I expect a sweaty [ __ ]
everywhere they
I didn't put them in the same level as
like you know
like royalty and [ __ ] yeah but they
definitely see themselves that way which
is why I think you know you know what
maybe high fashion runway and the and
the like supermodels that get paid
[ __ ] probably they got their 50
Millions
according to jazz those supermodels got
to where they are by doing that hello
everybody
if you liked the video make sure that
you guys leave us a thumbs up because if
not I'm gonna find you where you live
and I'm gonna hug the [ __ ] out of you
with you other than that you know
there's like more videos up there bro
[Music]